[Music]
just put your head down do the work and
everything will change
sympathy helping fields yeah that's what
i wanted be a patient hello
[Music]
what's up t-family it's me garyvee i'm
super excited to be with you tuesday
august 25th
i miss you i miss you i miss you and i'm
excited to be with you
uh let's go into the comments real real
real quick before i say hello to dustin
it's been a minute um i was off the grid
for a week
which is nice it's gonna be back
michelle sun what's good blake stanley
on facebook what's good thank you green
with the hair i like it too
eric ferguson what's good what's good
what's up dan f
adam r jason brown from nc ashley
rodriguez what's good
from the sunshine state where's my
twitch family at
where's my twitch family at i see my
youtube fam i see facebook coming in
hard linkedin's
heavy big shout out to linkedin and
everybody on twitter
dustin what's good hello good morning
what's going on with you man um nothing
pretty much just
getting the collecting pokemons and
how's that going
i'm stalking a lot like a lot of
stalking really just
what uh what uh what's your best flip
for everybody who's watching
you might have saw my instagram post
yesterday i was on vacay i read a book
about contemporary art
my conviction in the top five percent of
cards
call it pokemon series one shadowless
call it
you know the best basketball cards call
it the very rare
inserts that are modern i'm very heavy
vintage
um you know 50s 60s 70s 80s
especially in basketball soccer
wrestling but
my conviction for this to be
art and currency and a very valuable
happy
like to have a hobby that makes you
money is the rarest thing in the world
that's where i see this
but you know dustin you were around this
since you've been on team with garyvee
how long have you been on the team uh
just over two years
right so you saw right from day one when
i started kind of like
chirping yeah and it seemed out of left
field
yeah you didn't pay much attention to it
you thought it was gonna be one of those
kind of classic things that i was on for
a few minutes and you know
yeah then it got hotter and hotter but
you got in
very late on pokemon right when did you
buy your first card
uh july 3rd july 3rd of what
this year no i think
i think so i looked back at my ebay just
because i was like man i feel like i've
bought a long time ago but i think at
maybe the earliest june 28th
but but i felt like okay nonetheless
give me give me
because i want you to educate people
what did you buy a card for
and what's it what can you sell it for
right now on ebay um i bought
a char first edition charmander
uh psja10 for perfect grade charmander
yeah for 600
it would be like 630 or something like
that
the last one i saw sold for just under
2000 like
1995 or something like that so dust for
you know knowing your financial
situation like like like what does that
feel like
to in like six weeks be able to be like
i bought something for 600 and i could
sell for 2 000.
it's like whoa this is crazy
i mean it's very tempting right now to
be like maybe i should sell it but i
know a lot of people are saying i should
hold it so i'm like
it's very in that not sure what to do
like i'm
because i i do like those prices i see i
keep seeing going up
but certain cards like i check back
their history and they're like
pretty much always the same and i'm like
well i'm trying not
but like those cards i kind of like but
i just don't want to
i want to buy something that also does
grow in value
yeah i mean i you know once you start
buying and selling some of these things
and continuing to make dollars
up you might have the freedom to go and
spend 500 bucks
on seven cards you like right anyway
all right let's get in the show i miss
it cool
crazy comments on people's flips in the
comments section michael bought a donut
mitchell for 380 sold for 1300.
joe what's good gary how are you buddy
welcome back to the world
thank you man it's good to be back i
hope your vacation was good i hope that
you got to relax
thank you yeah thanks for having me man
i appreciate you great to see you
yeah good to see you i do i do
appreciate the hair i love it i can't
just find out right i was like i'm not
gonna overthink it
what's going on uh you know uh getting
back to work which is good you know been
uh
a couple of the shows have gone back
into production you know in this new
crazy covert world but we're doing good
you know getting back to work is nice
are things going are live action like
are people starting to film again
yeah yeah we're able to uh we're able to
do some uh we're in pre-production now
and with you know
just being careful when we're out there
on the public we'll have to be okay and
then we're doing
a show from home called dinner party
where we just basically have dinner over
uh with each other remotely from our
homes which has been kind of fun to do
so uh that's been great and we're doing
that again now and uh
my coat my covert projects are going
good i have my my books coming out i did
a book while i was locked up
called the dog father about my about my
dogs i love that oh my rescue
it was really fun i actually i didn't
like i've always been a self-starter
like you know so i've always like i
taught myself the program i
self-publishing i took all the photos in
my house it was
it was a really fun project i'm proud of
it so joe you know
based on your career just because i push
it so much
tell everybody how overnight success you
were like
please thank you please please paint the
picture for people on how powerful
first tell everybody who you are because
there's probably a segment that doesn't
know but
the majority do based on the comments um
you know where you are in your career
but
truly truly teaching patients a little
bit there's so many people in here
that are destined to win and achieve
what they want
but they're really the real one variable
that i think will stop them from getting
there
is lack of patience not enjoying the
process of eating
[ __ ] right yeah just would love to get
your
perspective on it just knowing enough
about your career to know that
you know i don't know i i'd like to even
hear it yeah yeah
well i i've we formed a comedy troupe uh
i'm joe gotta from a practical jokers
uh a member of the tenderloins comedy
troupe uh me and my
four best friends uh are on the show uh
we met freshman year at high school
so i know them over 30 years at this
point um
and we basically started an improv
comedy troupe and tried
and failed for about 16 years of trying
to come up with different ways to
quote unquote make it uh either tv or
movie or whatever and uh we had a couple
tv shows that didn't make it they just
made pilot and never went to series
and we finally stumbled upon our version
of impractical
impractical jokers which is our version
of a i guess a hidden camera comedy show
where we
make each other the butt of the joke and
we're in our ninth season now
uh so we've been doing over 200 episodes
and we're fortunate enough to
16 years of failure yeah with such a big
group
you know it's not just one person yeah
you know
well and i don't know this so you're
gonna answer for me did some guys
quit and take real jobs like like what
happened
like when was the close if i asked you
what was the single closest moment to
this
actually not happening what what was it
what year was it what was the
circumstance
it was it was about one week before we
came up with the idea from practical
jokers
swear to god last idea yeah it was our
it was our at the buzzer three-point
shot like it really was we were uh
and it was me i had uh we had gone the
stuff we were doing we've gone down the
path of like acting where we're doing
sketch comedy
and i'm not i'm funniest when i just do
this this is my type of human so i made
my friends laugh it's just me
being me and i'm not necessarily an
actor i always want to be behind the
camera
direct produced like that so i was like
not really comfortable with the way it
was going i was like guys this isn't
i i love you you know but this is not
for me it was always a side hustle
we had four we had four or four of us
all had separate jobs
during the even during filming we would
sal was a bartender
so he would leave go bartend at night
they'd come back and come to set and
film all day
q was a fireman new york city fireman it
would work he's 24 then come and film
all day
i was a baby store salesman i was a i
worked at uh this high-end baby store
called giggle where i would uh sell
hockey that was huge i probably i
probably bought a stroller from you
i wonder yeah yeah oh my i opened that
store
yeah on on what's lexan 74 or something
like something like right hand yeah
that's right there yeah yeah my girl
barb was the uh was the manager yeah
yeah she was
yes i i did that and then uh you know so
we were all doing that and for
for two years but i had to they let me
take a hiatus from giggle
when i shot the pilot and then they
picked up the first season i needed six
months off and i was like hey
i need six months off i'll be back and
the ceo was like nah that's all right
you're quitting you're not so i was like
okay
so i i was the first one to jump out i
was like this thing's got to work guys
because
i i've given it up i put all my eggs in
this basket so
uh and since then you know just been
working hard and hustling but i think
for sure
i think for sure what you're saying is
like definitely the failure mold you
into the success you're gonna be
because if you don't have that failure
you're gonna be a guy who doesn't know
how to handle and appreciate success
and i think that's a big part of why
some of these people fade out or
to me it's kind of like the sports card
thing right now that i'm completely up
like
joe i'm i'm not joking there's now a
30 chance that i'm gonna quit everything
i do
and become a full-time sports card
trader
that's fantastic and it is fantastic and
it's weird because 30
is a big number you do you do a thousand
percent of stuff so
that's right but but but i'm telling you
like literally like
it's it's because because what i
recognize in it
is when you love your process
you're in your best spot and you know
being honest to myself listen i'm
so in love with tea with garyvee garyvee
content
being this bus you know the ceo of my
big companies
and all this i really love it but man
doing research to two o'clock in the
morning on ebay and google
to like see if i can find an angle in
sports cards that like some weird
like there's a sugar daddy remember
sugar daddies
you might you're better to find that
gary they're getting yourself in trouble
right thank you sorry
your finger daddy the candy not sugar
like some of the guys that are watching
right now are living you know
they had a sports car that was very
weird because the candy was weird you
know like a very weird shape
um nonetheless like
it literally literally is this set
that's kind of worthless
and i'm like actually i don't think it
should be
or maybe it's not going to be because
it's more rare than the regular cards
from these athletes
so like like going through that
intellectual process of trying to find
things that people don't see which i do
with social media and marketing and what
i'm known for
in the form of trading cards
with the psychology of art in that kind
of like
i've always it's why i love garage
sailing this notion of i'm gonna buy
this for 38
on ebay but i really think i'm gonna
sell it for nine
thousand dollars in 12 years when the
world decides wait a minute
this hank aaron's card from 1954
made by a cookie company is so much more
rare than tops
right maybe it's actually worth much
more than cops
instead of much like that [ __ ] yeah
i love my process the same way that i'm
sure you guys did gigs
bombed especially because you guys are
east coast guys so like
we're not a minister you know we're not
in milwaukee where people will be a
little more cordial
this is like literally like guys yelling
at you and saying like get the [ __ ]
touching you not even boo
like you know um but then you i picture
you guys having a beer afterwards
and kind of going into that sucked
and was the [ __ ] best yeah yeah i
mean
everybody's watching right now so many
people want to win
get followers make money if you can get
into the world of
that [ __ ] sucked and it was the
[ __ ]
best yeah is that true would you agree
100 yeah you gotta
you gotta enjoy what you do like you
know fun and the failure that's
basically
the mantra you have to have you gotta
have fun while you're failing because
that's that fire you're talking
about like anything anything you think
about when you can't get something off
your mind
i mean that's the thing you need to
chase that's all you got to go after it
you know either if it's
whatever you want to do if that thing
keeps whispering in the back of your
head that's you got to listen to the
whisper sometimes i think
i think that's right you have any
questions before we get out of here i
would love
i would love one but everybody first of
all i i just want to tell you
fanboy a little bit i love you i love
what you do i love your messaging
you're fantastic i think it's important
especially for the kids today to have
people look up to
and i have two kids and i'm thankful for
people like you out there
so i will say that i've also been called
the garyvee of comedy i don't even know
what that means
but handsome and smart that must be it
but uh you i am very much like you i
come from you know like a place where
[ __ ] what other people think
um but there's also a line there and i
and i talk about that and i teach about
this line too but
what you always say you don't give a
[ __ ] what other people think but what
are your thoughts on not caring what
other people think
versus listening to constructive
criticism that's coming your way that
you don't want to hear
i only believe in the audience
it's almost like oh joe you i don't l
i'm not in love with constructive
criticism
from somebody that's in between me and
the audience
i'd rather go to the audience let them
[ __ ] on me i love that
they're only right the the world is only
i sit here with this weird thesis
of sugar daddy cards but if they fail
the audience was right i wasn't
somebody who's been in the sports card
business for 20 years saying to me hey
i've been around the block kid
these won't be anything i don't believe
it it's actually
ironically what's happening in sports
cards it's what happened in the wine
business it's what's happening with
vayner media
so you grew up in a world where somebody
had to say
yes for you to get to the audience yeah
so you had to very much have a different
relationship
with another human being's constructive
criticism
aka their opinion yeah
i got really addicted to the internet
and still am you know everyone's very
mad at it and it's bad and the russians
and i get it
but it is still the platform that does
not have a gatekeeper
that lets me be me this show
like i'm brushing my teeth six minutes
before i'm you know
calling wine library to get there like
and i'm like boom i'm here we're here
and nobody's in our ears right now
saying like no less of that or
don't say [ __ ] again gary are like like
so i i'm a very big fan of not
letting somebody else's opinion dictate
your happiness because it's actually
doesn't come from like an east coast you
know rugged [ __ ]
everybody it actually comes from empathy
i know that nobody knows me
right right right joe like like they're
making a hot take
on a moment in time yeah i think you
need to like
cheer people to what i do too it's like
i have tears of friendship and we joke
about that but if somebody gets
in your life in a way and when they say
something it sounds different than
somebody else
it's funny you say this you know i i say
this to a lot of entrepreneurs that have
had some level of success
who are really struggling like this is
where comedians have an incredible
advantage
in the new world most people have thin
skin and can't put out content because
they're so sad when people leave
negative comments
right that's why stand up is so hard in
some way joe
i think almost everyone's doing some
version of stand-up not as hard but like
they're putting themselves out there
and right getting judged yeah getting
judged
and and i've been thinking a lot about
this
i struggle with people
judging me in the comments around
business
because i've accomplished things and i
would need to know what they've
accomplished
to allow it to carry away it's kind of
like athletes like i laugh when me and
my buddies sit around
and critique paul george
[Laughter]
he's one of the 50 best players in the
world
none of my friends on this 30 person
chat throughout the other day that are
taking a complete [ __ ] on paul george
and i'm saying to myself this guy's one
of the 50 best players in the world
right now
and none of the people on this thread
can make three consistent jump shots
wide open
they call them a piece of [ __ ] oh come
on man
and for me when somebody's like garyvee
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about and then i go to their
account and i spend 10 seconds on them
like
i have my 23 years of work and success
you know you have a fake gucci watch to
try to make yourself feel better
i'm gonna be okay so to your point
you've gotta quant you've gotta judge
the judger
i respect criticism but uh um
i i respect people's opinions i i i like
hearing it
but i only believe in the audiences the
end consumer
yeah smart yep that's great i love this
good answer gary gary's good at somebody
nothing can take over i just got to grab
this coffee take care
bye joe love you i guess i'm taking over
thanks joe
thanks for having me man i appreciate it
all right um well we're supposed to have
doug bob's next um
but gary needs to make coffee first you
know i mean
talking on the phone now what the hell
oh god um i'm gonna wait to bring on
doug
because i'd rather have doug and gary
talk
together but
actually yeah [ __ ] it bring it
bring you on real quick hey doug what's
up
how are you good um
gary's on the phone
uh wait uh where are you calling in from
i'm in baltimore so he's oh so not too
far
nice there he is dustin make sure you
stand by because i it's just coming up i
haven't grabbed it yet
doug how are you gary vee man i'm so
thankful to be on here i mean
you i've been following you for so long
i don't know if you remember me i met
you at vayner last year
i was on the 1 37 p.m podcast and i ran
into you in the bathroom
and we got a selfie in the bathroom and
i gave you a copy of my
newest book at the time and um i've been
following you for so long you've been so
inspirational my success
and just a little bit about me is i'm a
former convicted felon
fitness saved my life when i was
incarcerated i've since been on a
mission to help others use their
adversities to their advantage
through my content speaking coaching
books and my adversity advantage podcast
and i know that you believe
adversity is the foundation for success
i do and my question for you
is what was the hardest time you have
gone through as an entrepreneur
and what types of things did you do in
that situation to use that adversity to
your advantage
the truth is that probably the hardest
point i've ever had as an entrepreneur
was
towards the tail at probably somewhere
around 30 to
probably around 2005 when you know i was
on this mission as a kid to build this
big business for my dad
and my mom and i owned none of the
business i was
massively growing the business but i was
getting paid
very little because it's a family
business i understood
but i basically had a you know my 22 to
34
i had a job
because and and i was grossly underpaid
because i was dr running the business
um and towards the end
i struggled with that you know like i
started to
i think it's fair to say resent you know
like it's tough to build something from
3 to 60 million
make you know 70 60 40
you know through the years 40 50 60 70
80
000 instead of what somebody else would
be doing if if i wasn't my dad's son
i'd be getting paid a million or two
million a year
so i lost twice on paper
you know i didn't own the business i
knew i was a superstar
i looked like a loser because i was
working for my dad that's just how
people looked at it
i was okay with most of that because i
didn't give a [ __ ] about the outside but
i was starting to resent
because i'm like i'm [ __ ] building
this i don't own this
you know and then after all that i go
start zero
and i start building something again and
then people are [ __ ] on me of like
oh you took daddy's
they don't know my story right i think
so many people you're right
so many people will judge somebody based
on
the surface level stuff and they don't
see the back end they don't see the
climb they just see you at the top and
they're like
you know that guy had it handed to him
but really they don't see the hard work
you put in i mean bro
bro [ __ ] hard work i got the reverse of
handing to me i
handed [ __ ] to people and then started
over
like bro i've got real [ __ ] feelings
about this
because people try to use the fact that
my dad had a business people i
my dad had a three million dollar a year
business 3.8 actually to be fair to him
but it was making 380 000 in gross
profit
and then that was before expensive it
was a small business
like i could paid more in two speeches
than my dad was taking home
you know like like but but
but my dad came here with nothing right
like zero
it's insane what he accomplished man
didn't speak english in 1978 owned his
own store in 1983
late 78 you know so like he
killed it but bro that doesn't take away
from like you're asking me my struggle
my struggle was
i [ __ ] demolished it
but didn't get the personal financial
value from it
then started a new business and gave 50
of that business to my brother
on day one because we're partners and
struggled with that because i was
driving more of the business like
my biggest struggle has been my whole
career i've been in family businesses
where i was the [ __ ] number one but
my financial
ramifications for being the number one
was nowhere close to being justified for
what i
deserved and and i'm so grateful for my
wiring
that i love my brother my dad
more than i care about the dollars and i
was able to get through
and it's all good but i hate when i'm
trying to help people win
that people try to throw around that i
was handed something
you know you know handed something
to to get to where i got to when in
reverse
i've been handing out and still i'm here
yeah i think it goes so much into what
you do now and how much
free content you give away to help other
people and i think
that's what i'm doing now bro right bro
i should not be telling anybody about
what i believe in sports cards and
pokemon cards
i could be gathering that all for myself
big shout out to kahuna who just on the
comments patrick patrick i know you know
what's going on with the sports cards
because
anthony you better get [ __ ] serious
but like bro it's my
it's my nature i'm my happiest when i'm
giving
um yeah amen to that and like the last
thing i
want to ask on that is why do you think
so many people make their struggles
like worse i believe that like when we
hit hard times we have a choice
we're either going to use it to our
advantage or we're going to make the
make matters worse like why do you think
people just sit in the
in the struggle and struggle even more
dna parenting circumstances
you know the the
your parents siblings and your three to
seven best friends
and then a coach or a teacher or a
grandparent like
there's 17 people that shape you right
there's one to 17 people that shape you
who that is is a huge factor i was
shaped by my mom the most
positive loving supportive self-esteem
building
but with rules and [ __ ] discipline
and like no [ __ ] and no [ __ ]
no 8th place trophies i'm the byproduct
of that then i go into my dad at 14
the guy's completely like lying is the
devil and
like sucks [ __ ] out of me
from 14 to eight you know i'm i'm the
byproduct of that
um i'm also not i also like didn't speak
english
when i'm five in dover new jersey i
don't even bring up dover we lived there
for a year i always say we went from
queens to edison i've always wondered
this i'm like
like why don't i bring up dover we were
there for a year before i went to edison
it was a quick stop
is it because i got picked on so much
that kids would hand me like
i'll never forget the four kids in the
neighborhood 1980 i was five
five and a half and they're like like i
remember it vividly right now they
literally forced me to drink this pepsi
can i didn't want to because i knew
something bad
because i could feel the energy but i
drank it because i was getting bullied
and they peed in the pepsi can like you
know
i was a bad at school i wasn't good at
sports i'm i
i lost my entire 18 years of my life it
didn't seem
that way because i had a good
personality i was happy i had friends
but the world but the world
wasn't telling me outside of my little
[ __ ] cocoon of my own [ __ ] head
and my sister and my mom before aj came
because he's 11 years younger than me
the world was giving me no indication
that it gave a [ __ ] about me
and so for me it's really easy not to
give a [ __ ]
because they didn't give a [ __ ] about me
first
absolutely i love that and i appreciate
your time one bonus question is i know a
lot of people right now
are struggling to kind of break through
and get their message out there other
than content
if you i mean what would be like one
quick tip for people that content doug
content is oh content is how gandhi
broke through
content is how martin luther king broke
through content
is how hamilton broke through and
tupac and jay-z and [ __ ] hank aaron
like it's only content now let's double
click into that doug
for everybody who's watching right now
ashton and ozone and zeke
and cbd and oswam and gabriel rodriguez
they need to figure out how they
communicate
is it painting is it talking like i can
sit here for the last six minutes and
paint a very vivid picture through my
words
that [ __ ] hits a lot of people can't
do that
others can write a [ __ ] poem that
will make all of us cry
i can't do that [ __ ] so the answer is
content
the answer is what websites dominate
this device
linkedin facebook twitter it's
everything i'm live on right now
and then the variable of success is how
you fill it
like i can tell everybody right now
being a professional nba basketball
player
is a great strategy to make money over
the next
40 years if you can be a basketball
player it's a good idea it's a small
team
the tv money is huge we are all gonna
see the first
billion dollar a year basketball player
probably in the next 20 years right
right it's a good idea the problem is
are you good enough at basketball i'm
giving the right advice
the right advice is content every day as
much as humanly possible on these
platforms
the question is can you figure out how
to be self-aware enough to figure out
which platform and how
written word audio video and then number
two once you've realized oh i'm good on
video
do you have anything to actually say
i love that i love that because you got
to have a why behind everything and you
got to have the how right
the why creates the how and and
experience matters whether it's your
life experience because your story was
clearly based on what i'm hearing
without knowing every detail
it was raw it was real matters you know
for me i didn't start talking about
business
stuff until i was 34 and that meant
con you know realistically i've been
working and doing business for 28 years
conservatively for 16
if you want to talk about profession as
a grown-up um
but i still believe my baseball card
eliminates sand and shoveling snow and
you know my friend robbie turnick big
shout out made me laugh the other day
he's like you never talk about the story
that you're a nice jewish boy and you
forced all of us to go around the
neighborhood
ring the doorbell and sing christmas
carols i used to literally dug i used
literally as an eight nine year old
would ring the doorbell and be like
ma'am
would you like to hear i would bring my
sister and denise
denise big shout out to me slory and
robbie turnick and michael brofman if
you're out there andy greco luanne greco
eric godfrey i would gather my crew
ring the doorbell and be like ma'am
would you like to hear a christmas
carol and i and literally i was so
gangster i was like hit it boys dashing
through the snow like like
[ __ ] it was in me you know
that's awesome man when i started
talking about it it came from experience
not thoughts not guessing
yeah i agree and the last thing i'll say
on that is i believe that
at least for me it was very healing for
me to share my story and share my
message
and realize that there was purpose in my
pain and i think that you can look at
pain in two ways you can look at it
in a victim mindset and say woe is me or
you can say you know what this happened
for me
i'm going to take the lessons and wisdom
that i you know gain from this and then
serve other people with my message
and doug listen what you figured out and
kudos to you
is that the shadows
are the prison um what
like you can't imagine how much i hope
everybody heard you loud and clear
because for a lot of people right now
making one video
one video saying something they did that
was bad
or that they're ashamed of you know
that's why i talk about
peeing my bed until i was 11. you know
like
slowly but short listen i you know
talking about my true circumstance of
like
you know it's not fun to talk about like
you know struggling in a family business
especially when you love your your dad
the most
you know so yeah
yeah i mean i i promised my cellmate
when i left
jail i i said how can i repay you for
helping to save my life because he was
the guy who trained me in there
and i he said just pay it forward and
i've been on a mission
um for the last it's been almost 12
years to pay it forward so i want to
once again want to thank you for your
time this has been awesome
thanks doug thank you i wish you well
sorry you too doesn't take over real
quick for a second
well this is the pokemon segment of the
show now
because i'm taking over so
first thing you should do is figure out
what you want to collect
i would say uh i like to go with
the 1999 edition because it's one of the
first ones that were
in america and figured it's old
us older people probably had them as
we're a kid so it makes sense because
they're like oh i love that car when i
was a kid
that's why i decided to go with 1999's
but then the thing is there's different
versions of it
so there's a this is a squirtle
it's you can't really see in my camera
but there's a there's a little badge
here that says first edition
and i wasn't giving you the finger there
sorry about that um
but this one is called the shadowless it
doesn't have the first edition badge
but it still doesn't have this uh
shadow on the right side here where
this one is called the base set and it
has that shadow on the right see it
let's [ __ ] go just trying to educate
a little
about first edition first edition
shadowless versus unlimited
uh-huh yeah all right let's rock and
roll
hey what's up how are you i'm good how
are you
good congrats on all your success oh
thanks man yeah thank you so much for
having me on and thanks for you shared
my song on your story like a few months
ago or something very aware
thanks for the support tell everybody
who you are what you're doing
yeah so i'm a musician i've been playing
bass since i was seven
and um you know always hustled really
hard
whole life practiced really hard and
then
when quarantine started i posted on
tick tock for like the first time and
you talked about this a lot so i wanted
to just like get straight into it but
um yeah quarantine started and i just
started posting on tick tock like
one to three times a day and it kind of
blew up and like my account blew up
really fast and i had a bunch of like
viral videos
just of me playing bass like doing music
things and then
um yeah all my other socials started to
grow super fast
and then i put out a song um in april
and that song also like went viral the
app
and now has like 500 000 videos made to
it which is like really insane
so and now it's like all over the radio
and it's like it's it's like been really
crazy the past few months so
i think it's like number three most
added song on alternative radio right
now which is like
sick um yes
what does it feel like to have like your
actual dreams come true
and for it to happen in this like
12-week period oh man it's insane
because i always like
knew that like i was gonna get there you
know what i mean just because that's
like
the person yeah i just felt it and i
never like
didn't want to do music you know what i
mean like someone was like when did you
know you wanted to do music forever and
i always knew like i've been playing
since i was seven i just like never
not wanted to do it you know what i mean
so but yeah it's been really insane
because like every day i'll wake up with
like
really good news and it'll just be like
the weirdest feeling ever it means
it's amazing but like yeah i'm just
trying to take it all in and like stay
present
and enjoy it you know grow up um in new
york city
so i'm like born and raised in high and
yeah
and so what's the biggest you know i
talk a lot about
people that have good things going on
like i think people are very confused i
talk a lot about
knowing millions of millionaires who are
miserable as [ __ ]
yeah so you just literally talked
and i know that between this live stream
and if we chop this up and put it on
social like
over the next five years millions of
people will see it and be like oh my god
that is my
singular dream because so many people
dream right
what here's an interesting question i've
been dying to ask somebody in this exact
circumstance i'm glad i remembered
what's the biggest challenge like what's
the hardest thing right now
is it the cliche with so many more
people knowing you you're getting so
many more
people saying [ __ ] about you're not that
good or you're ugly or like that
normal [ __ ] bullying is it
oh [ __ ] like for me i love the process
like i swear to god blue
like i feared the day i buy the jets
like you can't imagine
really yeah because i feel like i'll be
there and i'll be like
[ __ ] now what right like now luckily i'm
like well now i got to win a super bowl
but but like there is a part of me i'll
give you an example
i love the week before a vacation more
than anything
i literally get a level of some weird
form of depression
the second the plane lands on the first
day
because for me it's the hype leading i
love the process
yeah and then when it starts it's like
oh no now it's gonna start
now the hourglass flips so for me i'm
such a process guy
so is that it like you've been loving
the years of like knowing in your head
like
these [ __ ] don't get it i'm
going to make it i'm going to make it
now
or is it something that i didn't bring
up like is it something completely out
um
i think i'm also sort of a process
person
and i think like the most like excited i
was during this whole time was like
right at the start of it and like like i
put out the song april 17th and i think
it was like
beginning of may that it really started
to like you know take off and i was just
like waking up and like
every day it was like something like
like your songs on the radio which is
like in me
like in my head i would have i wouldn't
have thought it was going to come this
quick so i think the thing that was like
the happening really fast was also like
really exciting to me
but now is where i'm getting like now
that everything's kind of popping off
i'm like a little bit more like stressed
out about it because i like because like
now is the time to
make new decisions yeah i have to make
new decisions and then like you know i
had the whole like
all the label discussions like that was
a whole thing that was um
that was really interesting to me
because like that's the other thing like
having all these major labels reach out
is another like
dream sort of come true because that's
just like a childhood thing like oh
do you have like manager yeah yeah i
like the best management
i love them and so did you have them for
a long time
um just for like a year about a year so
you were able to
form something before it's always really
nice to have that trust with them
during that process yeah totally and
they found me on youtube like when i had
no
like my my song had like 20 000 plays or
something when they found me so like we
really grew together and like
yeah i'm really like excited about my
whole team but i'm a process person like
when i was doing
when i was first doing the tick tock
stuff like it was keeping me so
sane like during the whole quarantine
because i would just like wake up get
dressed
make like three tick tocks like that
would be my day you know and i was just
like
why did you get serious about it did you
know it was possible
somebody like do you see another thing
did somebody tell you like
what pushed you so i like
heard about the app a while ago like
probably like
a year ago and i always had an account i
just never like did anything with it but
i
did you know it when it was musically
um yeah but i was never like into it
like i didn't know how
how cool it was and then i would like
kind of go on here and there and i just
like saw these like cool creative people
i was just like this is insane
and then i was about to go on tour i was
about to because i'm a touring musician
i've been like
touring as a bass player for a bunch of
artists for a while um for the past like
five years or whatever um and i was
about to go on this like four week
european tour and that
you know obviously got cancelled so i
came home and i was like should i just
do this and i had one right before i
went on the european tour i posted a
video
to like doji cats say so you know like
that huge song that was
it was popping like really popping at
the time and i woke up the next day and
i had like 100 000 likes
so i was like this is clearly connecting
and working with people
um so since that one popped off i was
like i should just do this every single
day
to keep the momentum going because
that's just like i just like i'm like
into all that stuff like i love
getting to know like that motivates me
you know
of course it's like it's process
progress yeah
and i saw that i don't know if you're
typing or if somebody else's mic is on
in the background but i hear that um i
think it's actually
blue i'm sorry yeah every time you talk
for some reason
i do hear it also i don't know why no
worries don't worry about it too much
blue
all right what's your question okay oh i
was gonna ask
so i'm about to put out a new song
because we've been milking this this
past song which is called figure it out
by the way
um we've been milking that past song you
know for the past months
and i'm about to put on a new song and i
was wondering just what your advice
would be
like leading up to the next song like
what i should be focusing and like
prioritizing right now do you have a
closed community uh do you
do you know that phone number thing
community yeah i have that yeah i have
that
right i'm so [ __ ] pumped right now
you just made my dad yeah i think
yeah i think you should play what's that
i think you should do you know your
phone number off the top of your head or
do you have to look for it
um i can look it up really look it up
right now we'll get some of the crew in
here to follow you like
i think you should do something with
that
okay interesting yeah i think you could
do something um
yep nine wants to try to say it out yeah
dustin's good like not okay nine one
seven
five four zero eight five two one
right so i think that you should you got
that dust
there we go so everybody check out what
blue's doing here like
you know first check out our songs see
if you want you know because texts are
kind of like
your your place but i think you should
do something super special for your
community i think you should
take a couple days build this up be like
like everybody on social like
i'm popping this off off for 24 hours
first to my community
yeah then put it on some sort of secret
url whatever you decide to do
whether it's a password in youtube or
you know i'm sure you and your team can
figure it out
but i think i think this is your
opportunity to thank everybody who loves
you
and i and people love early access
yeah totally like we did that with um
yeah we did that like with like my merch
drop and stuff and i like
i go through and i like respond to
everyone like i'll send like some math
stuff but i'll like
go through and respond to like everyone
individually because like i think
i think that's important getting access
to something as big as a new song
is a super value prop because you're not
asking them for money like you are with
merch
so i would think about playing with that
first i i really think that platform
has the opportunity for new launches in
a very interesting way
mm-hmm yeah that's a that's really
interesting
i'll definitely i'll definitely do that
yeah because i'm
so you think i should be spending the
time now just really connecting with
individual people and like yes
growing that fan base instead of like
and like tick tock too i guess just like
people
i think you know and i've been i've been
watching you for a little while as you
may know like
so i think you have the potential to
have an offset even like the way you're
talking right now which is affirmation
for my intuition
i have a funny feeling that everybody in
the comments is like wow this is a young
woman
this is crazy composure she's got like
such a big thing going on but look how
normal she is look how thoughtful she is
that speaks to me in a very interesting
way because i also know how talented you
are
at base you're an actual musician
what that speaks to me is like your goal
because you love your process is to
become the grateful dead
or fish or lady gaga and what i mean by
that is
to i think i'm fascinated by musicians
that don't realize
uncomfortably loving their fans
like like fish dave matthews like
uncomfortably loving your fans
leads to you being able to do it for the
rest of your [ __ ] life
taking them for granted whether that's
because you got your own [ __ ]
issues in real life or because you take
them for [ __ ] granted
is the easy way to have four great years
and then not yeah
you're right yeah so yeah like i i
when i tell you blue like this is real
from 2007 to 2011 i would spend
15 hours a day replying to people on
twitter
one by one and answering every email
before i'd go to sleep at two or three
in the morning
that became my foundation
yeah cause they stayed with you forever
so and by the way i [ __ ] with them
because my friend kahuna in here said
this already i switched from wine
content to business
so that was hard for a lot of people
like you're gonna be able to stay in
you're saying like
actually a lot of them had to make a
decision that they wanted to hear this
stuff on my mind
it may happen to me now i may transition
from business to sports cards
right i'm obsessed right now with
pokemon and sports cards blue
like do you like pokemon cards
um i haven't gotten into it but what
about magic the gathering did you
did you collect anything as a kid um
i mean like bases and guitars i love
that
you literally like they're like all
there
you know what i love about that it's
like the same thing as like if somebody
if
if 13 year old me saw me at the height
of my career at 44
spending all this time talking about
sports cards i would have been like wow
i can't believe how consistent i stayed
i love that for you too like what you
just showed listen yeah
i'm going to leave it with this because
i'm going to the next one please love
your fans
more than they love you totally that's
great advice
just figure it out six minutes a day
yeah let me tell you something that will
work every day of the week
just go to twitter search your name see
one [ __ ] fan say that you're the best
in the world
make a video and be like karen thank you
so much and reply with that video
do that once a day for three and a half
minutes a day
like it's the best yeah
that's the best sig thank you so much i
really appreciate
it well thank you okay cool
bye
let's go so nervous
hi michelle where are you from i'm from
georgia amazing what's going on
so much for what you do i watch you like
every day
you've really changed my life thank you
how so
oh my mindset like i was
basically before i was following you i
was
just trying to find out what would make
me the most money in life
and um i graduated with a marketing
degree went straight into sales for like
a year
and um i don't want to say i hated it
because my first job was pretty good
i'm so nervous i'm sorry don't worry
you're doing well my first job was
pretty good but my second job
i was so miserable like i i was just so
depressed
and then i decided to move home good
and now i'm living with my parents and
i'm
kind of trying out different things
because i've always wanted to be an
entrepreneur
um and maybe not on like a huge scale
but
just doing something little by myself
because i don't know it makes me excited
that's good how do your parents like
having you home they love it i'm really
close with them
so close to my parents too like i i
spent a lot of time with them during
this quarantine
and like it wasn't enough like it's so
fun like i
i actually would live with my parents my
whole life like super down for it
i love it i just um i'm gonna be getting
married in like a year so then i'll be
moving out but other than that i would
live here forever
i love that i love that i love that i
love that what can i answer for you
okay so um my dream since i was like 13
i'm 22 now has been to
be a content creator and i'm still not
sure what i want to do
um like what topic but i've just been
making like tick tocks like
following trends or like random thoughts
throughout the day
um but i get really put down by
people's comments and i've been watching
what you say and like
how you say don't listen to them but i'm
just like a really soft person i'm
really sensitive so i have a really hard
time let me help you let me help you let
me try to help
yeah the biggest thing the biggest thing
that um
um that you need to realize is they
don't know you
and there's two things you have to you
have to be empathetic
and feel bad for them like do you want
michelle listen to me
do you know how sad of a place somebody
is in that they have taken the time to
watch your video
and say something to make you feel bad
so that you can feel bad with them
do you understand how sad one feels
like i i'm not joking and i think people
think i'm just trying to cheer somebody
up
i'm not joking when people say [ __ ]
about you like you're ugly that's stupid
you're not funny you're dumb that's
wrong you don't you you like
i don't know how to do anything other
than feel really bad for them
yeah it's what's really hard for me is
like i have a lot of confidence in like
my abilities and like i believe in
myself a lot but there was a lot of
people like commenting on my appearance
which is something that i can't
help and i just think it's like a
horrible thing to do and
for some reason i believe it every time
like i believe that they say i'm ugly i
believe it and it makes me like not want
to post anymore
look i we all have confidence and we all
have lack of self-esteem i in places
for example michelle i can walk into an
arena right now
with 80 000 people right now if somebody
called
and said we need you it's the first
public gathering in new jersey
you have to give a one hour keynote
we're outside you have to go right now
we're going to the jet stadium that life
stadium you have to go right now
now i would be so pumped i'd be thrilled
i'd be like in the car thinking what the
[ __ ] am i going to say i'm going to be
like all right [ __ ] corona
you know like um right i can do that if
somebody called me right now and said
on t with garyvee you have to read
right now here's a piece of paper you
have to read this
i would be unbelievably concerned
i would be super like self-conscious
because
i am a very poor reader and like like
it just really really really is anxiety
for me like sitting around
like during like very like the high
holidays
like reading at passover like like like
i'm scared with my like my family
so so you have a lot of confidence in
some areas and in other areas
you don't just like every one of us the
reality is though
you have to recognize that first of all
looks
beauty is uncomfortably subjective
it's just subjective and you have to
really understand that the people that
are
saying that to you are in a really bad
place
you're gonna have to figure this out you
know that right
yeah in a good way like it's just
practice
it's like working out it's just practice
so what are like
practical things that i can do like
actions whenever i get a comment like
that
like is it like a thought that i have in
my head like
yeah what can i do to build that muscle
i
everyone's different let me tell you
what i do when you feel exactly like you
just talked about
i think you should make pretend that
your parents died in a car accident
i know that seems super weird what i do
is i go to a place if i'm struggling and
i
create a scenario in my head that
actually speaks about real life
and makes me realize that johnny 97
talk talk saying that i'm ugly really
doesn't mean a whole lot
in a world where i'm driving now to the
hospital and i've lost my two best
friends
30 to 50 years earlier than i should
have
that's one tactic i'm serious that's one
tactic
that may or may not work for you the
other thing that you need to do
is go to a place of confidence for
example
i remember in high school very recently
i remember this when i would do
really poor in school and have a real
tough day when teachers really [ __ ] on
me
right which was never fun even though i
was confident
i would double go home and like focus on
my sports cards
like i would go to a place of confidence
right but the number one thing you need
to realize
is that it's in your own [ __ ] head
i'm laughing because i'm watching the
comments
of like so many guys being like i don't
know who said that but like what's up
like i'm ready to slide into your dm
like you have to understand
like you're you're deciding you're
deciding that that person's right
versus the people that tell you you do
look like you're deciding you're
deciding
i know and i hate that we all have
things we hate
but you have to realize you can actually
change it the most of all
and i'm going to give you something
really important
i think the thing you need to realize is
that you can't take compliments
in when you get them in whatever you get
them in
it's it's it's why it's so it's actually
why
i find the most insecure people around
looks
are actually the ones that the world
collectively agrees are beautiful
really yeah because they get so much
positive affirmation
they become susceptible to the negative
so much more i've been shocked as i've
gotten older through the years
like boys and girls like that i i would
argue
that the attractive are even more
vulnerable to the negative comments
because they take so much pride in the
positive comments
i think i think the reason that i can
deal with my negative comments
is because when i get a goat emoji or
i'm the best or i'm a hero or i'm a
especially with like now that sports
cards are exploding everyone's like you
are nostradamus
[ __ ] you you you say you don't predict
you predicted this
i hear that and i'm like i don't know i
don't
i almost don't it almost doesn't come in
which also doesn't let you're full of
[ __ ] gary
you were handed it it doesn't you
understand
yeah i think couple things one is
perspective
you know ricky thompson saying you're
ugly versus
your best friend you know dying from
corona is a big difference
yeah and those things can happen in life
and all of a sudden when they do
people realize why the [ __ ] was i
worried about other [ __ ] right
number two trying to really really go to
a
place of positivity immediately as an
immediate medicine it's only a medicine
because you got to really work on the
macro
but when you feel it immediately forcing
yourself into places that you make you
happy
as a quick juxtaposition which sometimes
makes you not dwell on the negative as
long
number three and the most important one
don't let compliments land either
okay i really appreciate that before i
let you go because i'm not letting you
go that easy
one of those three resonate or don't
resonate like talk
um i think all of them i don't think i
take compliments
to like heavily i think
about in other categories what about in
other categories
good grades uh
like other parents liking like not maybe
you understand
not things where you're vulnerable in
the other places
yeah in the other places yes like i i
always
my ready let me show you something all
those years when my
friend's parents were like gary you're
so nice i'm like luck of the draw dna
oh wow yeah you see
like got it yeah
yeah it makes sense because when i was a
teenager i basically
um i was always looking for like the
positive affirmation from people
and in school even up in college i was
always like
getting a's because i wanted my parents
to be proud of me i wanted to make other
people proud people be like oh she's so
smart
like so i guess yeah i don't really
take the compliments on tick-tock too
seriously but in real life i do
what else what about the perspective
what about
literally understanding that somebody on
tick tock that's like why are you making
these videos you're so [ __ ]
ugly versus the people you love more
than life
literally yeah terminally ill talk to me
about that have you ever have you ever
you ever play that game have you ever
done that i've experienced it not that
someone's died but like i've experienced
being sad about something that's kind of
trivial and then something
really bad happens and then i'm like oh
why was i sad about that now like
i mean can you can you give me that
example i can't remember exactly what
happened but i do remember being in that
position
a few times good i'm trying to think of
it
let me help you even more if you can't
think of a specific time then the really
bad thing
wasn't really bad i'm talking real [ __ ]
with you
yeah you know really this really helps
me and i know this one's a little weird
and sometimes when i put this out people
are a little weird with me on it i'm
like look
nothing listen let this let the record
be stated forever
nothing i talk about do i think i'm
right everything i talk about
i know is right for me and i hope that
pieces of it might be right for others
period and the story signature done
so back to what works for me i'm talking
about real [ __ ]
i'm talking about really imagining
like the things that would make you cry
yeah
like who do you love the most give it to
me in the top five
my mom my dad my grandma my sister and
my fiance
great those five people dying
oh yeah like tell me like i always do
this like
on the day when you got your nastiest 50
comments
on tick tock you getting a phone call
from your mom crying that your grandma
died
how much do you give a [ __ ] about tick
tock
i would not care at all
that yeah
thank you so much you're welcome so much
please practice that
i will definitely well wanna make
pretend like i do
multiple times a week like sit there and
almost meditate like oh my god
this person died i'll never see them
again like
let it set in because what happens then
is when you go on your normal day
that other [ __ ] is [ __ ] trivial so
you think about it even when something
bad is not happening
like to just like throughout the day if
you're having a fine day you just think
about it
michelle i think about it every day
which is why every day is a good day
i like that it was so funny when you
just said when you're having a bad day
every day i have bad things happen
because i'm a very
involved in the world person people
try to drag me down business things go
bad
you know i have a thousand person
company companies getting sued
there's not a single day that i don't
have things
that would make other people because i'm
a real entrepreneur i'm full like that
like you know like every day i've got
[ __ ]
but because i do what i told you
it for me a massively
bad financial thing or or like really
like
nasty situation feels less
than one person on tick tock saying
you're ugly to you right now
and i want you to be where i'm at badly
so they don't [ __ ] matter 89 year old
michelle does not give a [ __ ] about
terence96's comment
in 2020 on tick tock
yeah the [ __ ] are you worried about
being ugly
or not being ugly anyway you got a
fiance i know
i don't know why i care
i think you said something super
ludicrous that i want to talk about for
a second what did you just say
to all the girls on tik tok that have
like the following or people on youtube
they're all
they look like models i feel like that's
the only way you know what a model
looked like 20 years ago
no she was skinny as [ __ ] and her name
was kate moss do you know what a model
looks like now
she's curvy as [ __ ] it looks like she's
from [ __ ] brazil
or to your point has the financial means
to have so much
plastic surgery that she can look like a
different version of herself or filters
or lighting
or angles what are we talking about here
and listen
i i will never go into these waters
fully because first of all i'm not a
woman
second of all there's so many dynamics
in play here but let me promise you
waters that i'm very comfortable
swimming in
other people's opinions are the greatest
way to go to unhappiness
one opinion you of yourself
is the easiest way to get to happiness
you hold too much value
in the collective outside world's
opinion
and you need to systematically from this
day on chip away at that
and make them matter less okay because
what you're doing is you're playing one
big game of junior high in high school
yeah i hate it i really read it can't
let your life
i watch 30 40 50 60 year olds every day
still live in high school i see 25 year
olds still living in high school
that what that's not fun
you know there is embarrassed you're
[ __ ] helping so many people right now
you're a reverse of course really you
should see what's going on in the
comments
you're listen to me you're talking about
what is on the mind of 98
of young women in the world and i hate
that
any different than anybody else on this
every single woman and guy for that
matter under 25 is in this mindset
yeah people care too much and there's
and now there's numbers around
popularity yeah
just wish people would like collectively
people would be valued for like how kind
they are
and how what you think we're trying to
do out here
huh that's what that's what i'm trying
to do out here
yeah that's why you like my show that's
why you
that's why i've helped you we're not out
here talking about numbers
i'm out here yelling that facebook and
instagram and youtube should hide the
following count
when i'm one of the biggest
beneficiaries of it
i want to gone because i but by the way
this is not facebook and tick tock and
instagram's fault
this is human being's fault
[Music]
we can't have our value tied
up in other people's opinions
ginger a great community member said
metric suck they don't suck
our interpretation of them suck
the following count and likes don't suck
we suck at valuing
that over what we want to say and who we
want to be
in the world
you could easily win this game michelle
you really can
i'm gonna try it every day i'm telling
you it's about perspective getting into
simplicity
not valuing other people's opinions that
don't know you understanding that it's
judgment what do you think every guy's
the hottest in the world
no well guess what what the [ __ ] what's
the problem here like
like what yeah you know how
unhappy so many of those girls you
admire are
i have unlimited messages from them
about their unhappiness
you know how not fun it is when you're
26 and you're smart as [ __ ]
and you know a ton about health and
wellness or wine or sports cards
but because you're so attractive the
only affirmation you're getting is when
you show tna
you know how you know sad that is i
can't imagine
it's real it's just like somebody who's
wealthy who was born into it who's sad
and everyone said well i'll take that
like
like you know everybody wants to live in
somebody else's shoes until they live in
somebody else's shoes
yeah there's unhappiness in every single
way
you can be lucky that you're the version
of what's beautiful at this moment let
me promise you this when i was in junior
high having a fat ass
was not hot
you may get lucky that your looks are
matching what the current world's
version of beauty is but that doesn't
have
anything to do with [ __ ] happiness
beauty is
so [ __ ] subjective yeah i really want
to get to a place where i don't care at
all
the way not to care at all shallow
the way not to care at all is to value
kindness and empathy it's to value
who somebody is not what they look like
yeah
you know you can do this but you need to
practice about perspective
like the helen the health and well-being
of the people you love
is so so important listen the world is
the world's going through such a
transformation i really believe
that kindness and things of that nature
continue to grow in importance and will
and people will be valued on that
but you have to value yourself
on that yeah that's real
it's very real michelle like you like
you have to value yourself
on that
i never thought of it like that but yeah
if you value yourself on who you are as
a human
then the then the things about
looks don't carry weight right now you
value too much looks
yeah i do which is why those things
resonate with you
you're so smart um you know what
i'm just fortunate
when it comes to a couple of very narrow
things and one of them is
just [ __ ] the simplicity of life
if you're willing to go there
it could be something do you feel like
experience taught you that or do you
feel like you were just born with
that mindset
both i got lucky with the dna
i got fortunate with my experience i got
unbelievably lucky with my parents i got
unbelievably lucky that i grew up
on my own two feet
and i got unbelievably lucky that my
talent is observing people
and understanding truths that are
universal
and then keeping it simple and then i
also got lucky in that
my great happiness comes from providing
happiness
and a million other things you know and
that's and by the way
that's why i don't think i'm special
that's why i'm deflecting when you say
you're so smart that didn't feel good to
me
because because it's back to like how
i've trained myself you know what i mean
like i don't want that like as a matter
of fact it's my biggest gripe with my
team
i don't allow them to we don't put out
content being about like i'm smart
because i don't think that brings any
value to anybody
i'm smart what does that do to me it's
like i'm trying to bring value
please please please get your life into
perspective you'll be so happy you did
every day hold your grandma
my grandma's 85. you'll be lucky if you
have another
100 hours with your grandma
every 20 minutes you spend on crying
about rick thompson
saying you look shitty is 20 minutes you
could be facetiming your grandma
no you're not gonna cry maybe i wanna
cry
perspective really helps michelle you
know what i mean
yeah you know all of a sudden
you like it's just these kind of this is
practice this is you and i are doing
push-ups right now
you know that kind of like helping
people realize things they don't see
when you realize holy [ __ ]
he's right 100 hours maybe
the hell am i laying here for the last
40 minutes dwelling about one comment on
tick tock
yeah that really put things in
perspective and it's those kind of
things
over and over and not just the one time
you were randomly on with garyvee
no no next thursday in the shower you
know
two weeks from now randomly when it pops
back up in your head and then you
practice and you practice and you
practice and what ends up happening is
now you are facetiming your grandma now
instead of dwelling you are making your
own content so you're on offense instead
of defense
and it did it did it and all of a sudden
and all of a sudden next thing you know
next thing you know this is now your new
life this is how you see the [ __ ]
world
thank you you're welcome is there
anything that i can do to help you
when i tell you that if you can one time
when paul shits on you
if you can just take that moment and put
it into
85 year old grandma time that's
a real win for me i can do that awesome
thanks for being on thank you
that's our show i'll see you soon dustin
thank you so much
i apologize ahead of time if we're in
the
last hours of me being this version of
myself because there's a substantial
chance
that i'm going to be sports card
cardboard gary cardboard because i i
like pokemon too
sorry to look into like garbage fail
kids and the a-team and star wars and
weird [ __ ]
i just might call myself cardboard gary
dustin wouldn't it be like the ultimate
like like what a crazy
crazy scenario if i like literally
literally yeah you know new ceo at
vayner x
you know like like if i literally went
like
talk about like
that'd be some [ __ ] that would be
very interesting probably the first
person to do that in history
oh what's really cool that's is a lot of
people
have done things like that you know
a lot of people we just don't know about
i guess
[ __ ] my sister did it i have so much
admiration for my sister
stay-at-home mom clearly loving it she
loves her kids more than breathing
but still needed something she could you
know could feel it as an undertone and
the version of who she is now as a real
estate agent
you know if you're a real estate agent
looking for somebody to team up with or
if you're com if you're moving to new
jersey like everybody is from manhattan
what's her what's her instagram handle
let's give her a little love right now
find it the melo e isn't it
i think so yeah it's uh liz nabello
actually
straight liz nobello
like put it up there go dm her
every real estate agent who's looking to
do some referral action
let's actually get everybody to follow
her let's explode her instagram my you
know i blew up my dad
and my sister's like super upset about
it
and she like really worked and like my
dad's at 58k
right actually if i've ever brought you
any value
this would mean a lot to me to follow my
sis my sister's at 39.
i'd love to get her to pass my dad but
here's
like here's a person who did it dust
like she thought her destiny was to be
a stay-at-home mom right no i meant like
the actual actual sports card but
yeah you're making that makes a lot of
sense too yeah listen
let me rephrase i wasn't sure where you
were going but i always think of like
what brings the most value
to the audience the thing that brings
the most value to the audience is it's
never too late
to disproportionately change absolutely
everything you're doing to make yourself
happier
for sure i think you believe in that
[ __ ] man i admire you
especially once i realized you were 63
watch this comment you ready i can't
wait to read the comments
dustin how old are you
i'll be 36 in november
wait i always forget this how close are
our birthdays
yours is the 14th mine's 29th
dustin is almost 36. yeah that's a zoom
in on
get in here a little bit
[Laughter]
yeah look the comments look bro i swear
you worked for me for a year and i was
like
he's 24. yeah i mean well the funny
thing is i always got carded
um this the entire time
and then once i started wearing a mask i
don't get carted anymore which is kind
of funny
you have a little bit older yeah i guess
so one place i see it
bro the comments are losing i'm telling
you you see it
they're losing
what a show yeah that michelle stuff was
interesting
i think the whole thing was i liked how
um i noticed something
who works in our company yeah
i just screamed holy [ __ ]
yeah freak of nature
you are i love you brother very very
much love you too talk to everybody
see ya thanks for watching the show talk
to you soon
bye